[Musique]
bonjour une griffe jean baptiste grange
à merci d'être présent dans ce studio
votre vous êtes martiniquaise de votre
présence en martinique est pas si
fréquente que ça puisque vous vivez vous
êtes base essentiellement aux états unis
et vous avez avec sonia jean baptiste
votre soeur s'est bien c'est votre père
c'est maintenant c'est ma manager c'est
la cofondatrice du chelsea film festival
voila voila l est pas loin votre
première sonia et vous-même donc vous
avez fondé alors votre maire était aussi
actrice
oui c'est ça c'est ça elle était aussi
actrice et elle était aussi dans la
photo dans l'industrie de la
photographie pendant des années et c'est
comme ça qu'elle s'est reconverti après
en tant qu'actrice et puis par la suite
producteur de cinéma voilà alors les
auditrices les auditeurs les internautes
ont compris que vous êtes
ça y est actrice dans le monde du cinéma
mais rappelez nous votre carrière si
vous êtes déjà fait pourquoi pourquoi
vous avez voulu fonder en 2013
ce festival du film de chelsea aux états
unis oui absolument à new york
alors pour résumer vraiment très
rapidement je suis né à paris j'ai
grandi à paris j'ai fait mes études de
d'histoire à la sorbonne avant ça j'ai
fait hypokhâgne et par la suite j'ai
j'avais envie de découvrir les états
unis donc je suis aller m'installer à
los angeles dans un premier temps et
dans le but en fait de continuer une
jeune carrière de journaliste ou j'avais
commencé à paris est
en arrivant à los angeles tout le monde
me demandait à mais est ce que tu es
actrice est ce que tu es mannequin et
j'attends moi je suis une jeune
journaliste et finalement c'est un peu
venu comme ça où j'ai pris des cours
d'acting de cinéma à los angeles et
petit j'en avais pris depuis l'âge de 5
ans mais jamais dans le but de devenir
comédienne ou actrice professionnelle
mais qu'est ce qui fait que finalement
vous êtes installé aux etats-unis en
tout cas vous est essentiellement basé
aux états unis
oui je crois que c'est la culture c'est
voilà c'est la culture c'est le rêve
américain qui m'a attirée depuis petit à
l'âge de 12 ans j'avais une
correspondante qui habitait à chicago et
je lui ai dit je vais je devenir jeu
venir te voir et elle m'a invité pendant
un mois chez elle et je crois que à ce
moment là j'ai commencé à comprendre ce
qu'était la culture américaine et puis
par la suite voilà après à l'adolescence
j'ai décidé d'aller découvrir d'autres
états donc los angeles et ensuite à new
york pour faire l'acteur studio voilà
donc une martiniquaise aux states
une martiniquaise actrice dans le monde
du cinéma est donc ce festival
international du film gay le chelsea
film festival donc organisation à but
non lucratif
oui c'est une association comme beaucoup
de festivals d'ailleurs
à new york et en général et c'est une ce
festival présente des films indépendants
absolue de réalisateurs émergents c'est
comme ça que c'est que que vous le
présenter c'est important mais alors ce
qu'il faut souligner c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est une île souligne évidemment
maintenant c'est que c'est officiel ios
est tous des a annoncé des résultats
d'un vote qui place ce tout jeune
festival du film de chelsea donc parmi
les dix meilleurs festivals de
l'amérique du nord vous est même classé
en sixième position
c'est vraiment un nanar comment commence
à s'expliquer c'est extraordinaire en
fait c'est c'est le fruit je crois du du
travail
peut-être l'originalité aussi de ce que
vous présentez émergents enfin bon voilà
oui c'est des films indépendants de
réalisateurs émergents voilà c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça exactement et puis
c'est une sélection internationale et
des longs métrages de fiction mais aussi
des documentaires et aussi des
documentaires et également des courts
métrages et un tous genres confondus
donc on a aussi des films d'animation et
et comme vous l'avez rappelé des
documentaires voilà on n'organise
vraiment pendant 5 jours 1
un événement qui est très complet avec
des master class avec des tables rondes
avec des networking events comme on
appelle ça aux états unis où les gens se
rencontrent des professionnels du cinéma
et les artistes émergents
alors c'est toute une équipe parce que
vous n'êtes pas que deux alors votre
maire et vous vous avez voulu créer ce
festival
mais je suppose que maintenant c'est une
large équipe qui en fait pas si large
que ça finalement c'est on est une
dizaine est pas à temps complet une
dizaine pendant à peu près la moitié de
l'année et on a une centaine de
bénévoles pendant le festival un
festival annuel c'est chaque année
absolument c'est en octobre chaque année
et cette année c'est du 17 au 20 octobre
voilà donc on a parlé de ce que vous
avez créé donc depuis 2013 mais vous
êtes aussi en martinique pour participer
au trophée créola 2019 parce que vous
allez être honoré vous allez recevoir un
trophée avec neuf autres femmes
oui pour baptiste c'est assez surprenant
c'est vraiment un honneur pour moi de
revenir ici chez moi en martinique et et
d'être honoré par ce trophée créé au là
donc c'est le premier magazine féminin
de la martinique
donc c'est pas rien c'est aussi le mois
de la femme le moins internationale de
la femme donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
organise c'est la deuxième édition et
avec d'autres femmes qui sont
extraordinaires
dont une footballeuse professionnelle
qui n'ont pas d'ailleurs être en
compétition mondiale prochainement et
une femme qui est aussi la directrice
d'un musée qui s'appelle le musée
gauguin en martinique que très peu de
gens connaissent ou alors on connaisse
mais je vous invite vraiment aller le
voir parce que c'est un musique
extraordinaire
donc voilà on est vraiment neuf autres
femmes donc je vais pas développer tous
les traits de chacune mais vraiment
c'est exceptionnel non cash très
heureuse d'être là quel est votre lien
en ce moment l'un d'eux avec la
martinique est ce que vous y venez quand
vacances ou est ce que à partir de ça
parce que bon voilà justement vous
comptez avoir aussi des projets de faire
peut-être des passerelles entre votre
pays d'origine et les états unis où vous
vivez le votre temps alors depuis
quelques années maintenant je viens
vraiment pour le travail alors j'en
profite parce que c'est une île
extraordinaire magnifique avec des
paysages qu'il faut qu'il faut profiter
c'est pas ces bagnards vous avez eu
l'occasion de vivre même en martinique
pendant plusieurs années où vous ne
veniez à chaque fois que pour quelques
courts séjours alors je depuis l'âge de
deux ans j'ai avec ma grand-mère en fait
j'ai découvert la martinique comme ça
avec ma grand mère donc dès l'âge de 2
ans je venais chaque année jusqu'à
ce cap et 25 ans pour par exemple vous
n'avez pas fait votre scolarité on
martin pas du tout venant à paris
ouais à paris est ce qui est drôle c'est
que moi je vous pose la question c'est
pas non plus un saisissent un peu voilà
oui qui la suit j'ai bien saisi et donc
finalement en m'expatrier ans aux états
unis il ya ce retour aux sources et je
crois en tant qu'adulte aussi de
découvrir la martinique différemment de
comprendre mieux la culture de
comprendre tout ce que toutes les
ressources vraiment de cette île quand
je parle de ressources je parle
particulièrement de la ressource
culturelles artisanat l'histoire aussi
qui est très riche et que et que l'on
nommé parfois quand on quand on vient
ici en vacances
voilà donc moi quand je reviens je
reviens aussi principalement pour le
travail j'ai tourné un film ici qui
s'appelle goyave qui a un film réalisé
par le réseau compte tendu par les eu
oui ça a eu un prix au festival de
courts métrages dont est là on n'a pas
eu le prix non n'a pas être primes ont
été présentés on a été présenté en
compétition et le film est en effet fait
le tour du monde non qu'on a on est
passé au fespaco qui est un festival et
nous voilà j'ai confondu c'est au
fespaco les 50 ans du fespaco le
festival du cinéma au burkina faso
absolument à ouagadougou et donc on y
est allé
récemment il ya pas si longtemps il ya
deux semaines
la semaine prochaine d'ailleurs le
réalisateur vient de partir à sonoma en
californie pour présenter le film jeudi
prochain il ya deux projections et donc
voilà donc on est là la huitième
sélection à des pyromanes octobre bon
alors ça montre c'est le premier
peut-être d'une série de collaborations
avec marc fini j'espère parce que c'est
bien de de parler de cinéma d'agir pour
le cinéma aux états unis mais ici on a
besoin on sait les mares absolument il
c'est aussi pour ça que je suis ici
parce que quand j'avais participé au
prix de court en tant que membre du jury
j'avais découvert énormément de talent
de jeunes talents et ça ça c'est
complètement en synergie avec ce que
nous ont fait aux états unis ont fait la
promotion de jeunes réalisateurs donc
nous on est vraiment bras ouverts quand
on reçoit des films qu'ils soient
semi-pro aux professionnels de la part
de des artistes martiniquais grid jean
baptiste donc vous aurez l'occasion
certainement de revenir souvent en
martinique
en tout cas vous l'espérez en attendant
vous serez donc honorer avec neuf autres
femmes pour les trophées créola 2019 ce
sera donc c'était hier excusez moi
c'était hier jeudi à 18h30
ça se passait au la vente à merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions voilà
émission réalisée par patrice à la guise
alacchi bonne journée et bon week-end à
vous tous et avoue tout rester à l
écoute de martinique la première